hi I'm Jessica Alba and I'm Gabrielle
Union and we are doing the wired
autocomplete interview yeah
like are you God does Jessica Alba know
how to dance yeah I do
that's funny that is a question your
honey Daniel I'm honey Daniels true
story did Jessica Alba go to college
nope does Jessica Alba have tattoos I
have a few I have this one Padma in
Sanskrit which is Lotus and it's the
manifestation of spiritual beauty got
that after a breakup and then I have a
couple of my kids star signs they're
sort of up my arm there you go
does Jessica Alba drink adult beverages
are something I do enjoy
I prefer tequila of the liquids for
adults does Jessica Alba speak Spanish
I wish of everything in life that is the
one thing I wish I could do how did
Gabrielle Union meet Dewayne wait the
first time I ever met Dwayne was at an
all-star game oh my god I know I'm a
huge fan and then I realized it wasn't
who I thought it was I thought that was
actually the first time I met him and he
was like oh my god and I was like oh
wait who are you what's your name
Dwyane Wade doesn't oh not quite that's
not who I thought it was how did
Gabrielle Union start acting I actually
got an internship while I was the book
buyback supervisor at UCLA at a modeling
agency called Fontaine and I was an
office intern I would call it
appointments for hayden Panettiere and
Shane West and Jessica Biel and then
they were wondering
if I would be interested in like
modeling and I was like yeah and I got
what I thought was the easiest
internship which was like I didn't think
working with models would be that hard
it wasn't and I got four units at the
time I was taking 20 units which was
very challenging because I was trying to
just finish college as fast as possible
since I was paying for it myself
how old was Gabrielle Union and bring it
on I would have been like 27 28 how was
Gabrielle Union how do you still like
discovered the modeling agency that I
was working at as office help making
making copies it was discovered that I
could read it they thought it it there
was a chance that I could you know
memorize a couple pages of acting sides
and then like literally the next week
they were like let's just make up a fake
resume and send you out an on audition
so I went in on our audition for Saved
by the Bell the new class and I booked
it and I've been working ever since the
secret was out she can read where
Jessica Alba lives Los Angeles where is
Jessica Alba from the suburbs of Los
Angeles I was born in Pomona California
but it was actually kind of raised in a
few different places my dad was in the
military I lived in Biloxi Mississippi I
lived in Del Rio Texas
laverne and San Dimas California home of
Raging Waters movie where Jessica Alba
is blind the eye I went and spent some
time at a Braille school an immersive
Braille program there's many different
sort of like tools that you can learn
how to go and and live very productive
lives and so I got to spend some time
there and really learn about all of the
great work that those folks do and how
important those types of immersive
schooling environments are where did
Jessica Alba meet her husband I met him
on the set of Fantastic Four he was
working for the director Tim story
what is Gabrielle Union real name
Gabrielle Monique Union now - wait what
is Gabrielle Union birthday October 29th
1972 what song did Gabrielle Union
walked down the aisle to which wedding
first or second the first one it was
endless love the second one was John
Legend actually performed at our wedding
and I walked down the aisle - how does
jeez it was a John Legend song kids John
help me out here what Gabrielle Union
what what Gabrielle Union eats like
daily like your caloric intake um I eat
everything very healthy uh yeah I tend
these days especially when I'm working I
stay away from gluten and dairy
I am currently though looking for a home
taco that has a lot of grease made with
real ground beef I don't want it a
freakin turkey ground turkey cuz that's
some bullsh
because I'm mildly hungover due to vets
aquila ties is Jessica Alba a singer
folks I'd have to pay all of you to
listen to me sing it's not bad can we
hear a little dope ah is Jessica Alba's
still acting you can find me in LA's
finest who is Jessica Alba mother and
father
Kathy Alba and Mark Alba or a really
good time they are instant BFFs to
anyone within reach
they love to crack jokes they enjoy
sports and large groups true story
what is Jessica Alba's background my
mother
is Caucasian her father is from Denmark
her mother is French American my father
is Mexican but I actually have a large
percentage of indigenous Mexican blood
in me I did a genetic test and Harry
gates did the test for me and he said
that he had never seen as much native
North American and any anyone as as he
didn't me so there you go what was
Gabrielle union's first movie my first
movie that I shot was 10 Things I Hate
About You
really mmm what is Gabrielle Union
zodiac sign I am a Scorpio a true
Scorpio don't try me and do you see this
empty basket effects it's empty because
I don't give one
what does Gabrielle unions baby name
mean I actually saw the name Tavia and
some credits on a film one 20 years ago
knows like oh that could be a cool baby
name and then I sort of switched it to
it kay but it turns out that the name
Kavya actually does mean something in
other cultures Kavya is a goddess in
another culture in our home
how Jessica Alba hair o how to Jessica
all of the hair I don't know I mean
today I definitely did not wake up like
this a hairdresser named Jennifer yep s
did my hair today
how is Jessica Alba right now I'm having
a little bit of a cold like a sinus te
bronchial situation my go-to
cold remedy is lots of ginger honey
lemon Oh a neti pot little flonase how
tall Jessica Alba I used to be hovering
at five seven but I'm pretty sure I've
shrunken so who knows
how old Jessica Alba well I was born in
1981 figure it out is Gabrielle Union
related to Oprah
what no where did that even come from
did they think all black people that
ever saw tan Oprah's couch are her like
cousins is Gabrielle Union from Nebraska
yes I am Omaha Nebraska go big red is
Gabrielle Union a Delta Sigma Theta
no I never pledged a sorority I just I
was the book buyback supervisor I worked
in the bookstore it's Gabrielle Union a
twin yes with Oprah cuz we're related
thank you so much for googling us thank
you we had a great time yeah
found out I was I was a twin and I'm
related to Oprah making decisions based
on what you're presented with is one way
to exercise your mind and learn how to
pay attention to the small things that
was a special agent with the FBI my job
was to catch spies retired Navy SEAL 21
years combat experience and now at
crisis management professional I've been
instructing professionally high-speed
driving with the United States and from
the government
if you take the time to evaluate walking
or driving that same route every day
you've just reduced a number of things
you have to pay attention to when
something bad occurs